نحن هنا في معبر رفح من الجانب الفلسطيني
نرصد عمليه دخول المساعدات التي تصل من
دول عده الى قطاع غزه الشاحنات تدخل تباعا
من الجانب المصري كذلك ايضا عبر معبر كرم
ابو سالم نرى شاحنه تحمل بعضا من
المساعدات الانسانيه التي تعبر في هذه
اللحظات عبر هذا المعبر الى قطاع غزه بعضا
من هذه المساعدات هي مساعدات انسانيه
والبعض الاخر مساعدات طبيه بحسب وزاره
الصحه الفلسطينيه فهناك حاجه ماسه الى
ادخال معدات لها علاقه في العمليات
الجراحيه غرف التخدير ايضا مضادات حيويه
ومعدات طبيه ومركبات اسعاف لها حاجه ماسه
وضروريه لعمل القطاع الصحي المنهك هنا في
قطاع غزه والذي يحتاج الى هذه المعدات
وهناك تدخل بعض من المعدات التالفه
ومنتهيه الصلاحيه والبعض منها معدات
كورونا ترسل من بعض الدول هنا الى قطاع
غزه ليست من الحاجه الضروريه وايضا فيما
يتعلق بكميات المساعدات التي تدخل الى
قطاع غزه واعداد الشاحنات لم تتخطى ال 150
شاحنه فاليوم دخلت نحو 80 شاحنه من الجانب
المصري عبر معبر رفح البري ونحو 100 شاحنه
تسلمها الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني ووكاله
الغوث الدوليه من معبر كرم ابو سالم بعد
ان تمت عمليه تفتيش هذه الشاحنات
رغم محدوديه الشاحنات التي تعبر الى قطاع
غزه كما ونوعا الى ان الفلسطينيون
يعتبرونها القشه الوحيده التي يتعلقون بها
من الغرق في مستنقع الواقع الانساني
والصحي الصعب في قطاع غزه هان الشاعر
لقناه الجزيره مدينه
رفح